this is a production of Cornell
University
hello everyone my name is Michael gore
I'm coming to you from this section of
plant breeding and genetics so the
question of the day well perhaps this
isn't a question today for you but it's
a question day for me that it will pose
to you is that how the mic or get into
high support phenotyping let me go back
to my days of being a graduate student
at work buckler's lab we had this
population of 5,000 recombinant inbred
lines called the maids NAMM population
and it took an army of people to plant
in an army of people to phenotype so
after all those countless days of having
to do plant height year high enter
flowering time out in the field I began
thinking of way to do high to predict
phenotyping one of the ways that we had
thought about doing - foot phenotyping
was perhaps having a plane fly over the
field which we had the other way was
having a large helium balloon tied to a
four-wheeler and pulled through the
field and a nice expensive camera
attached as well we began doing that and
driving back and forth through the field
but sometimes the wind would pick up and
there would be some tension on that line
it was a little scary but we were all
pretty sure that that line was strong
until one day it snapped and I remember
our field manager Nick calling the
police and asking them if they would
shoot the balloon out of the sky
I'm so thankful for humanity that they
did not do that and for all we know that
cameras in Canada somewhere and it's
being used but thankfully I didn't allow
my height uppity no typing dreams to
float away that fateful day so in in
2009 I accepted a position to work in
the USDA in Maricopa Arizona which was a
great decision on my part
but in the vironment was very harsh for
Huen and for growing plan but I kind of
viewed it as a test track for plants and
it's a great environment for testing for
heat and drought stress and I was hired
to work on cotton so coming from the
maize community and at that time working
on the first generation haplotype map of
maize realizing I was going to have to
dedicate my life to working out in the
field maybe the only people I would make
proud would probably be Marc's laurels
because I would actually go out to the
field what I didn't realize at the time
when it had my interview there in
January is it gets really hot and when
my family and I moved back out in June
there were so many four-letter words
drops that day but you know what we
adapt just like the plants but some of
the challenges such as when you think
about cotton trying to sustainably
produce it we in the face of global
climate change the patterns of weather a
highly variable right now and our
freshwater resources especially when I
was living in Arizona when we were
drawing down the Colorado River when you
actually see it firsthand it is quite
dramatic and here when we're looking at
the Cotton Belt right here of the US and
this was taken in 2011 here this is
where there
the co-occurrence of a severe drought
and just to have an idea of like the
economic impact of what a drought can
have this caused 2 billion of economic
loss in cotton production what is some
of the consequences of that we see it on
the news but really it's impacting human
beings and so when I was hired this is
kind of a charge that I Excel burdened
with that I felt I had to carry is how
are we going to turn that engine of
evolution and plant populations fast
enough to generate these resilient
cultivars to help provide fiber to the
world but also provide a source of
financial income to the farmers such as
this one in Garfield County Texas and in
2009 began thinking a lot about genomic
selection and of course you know we
could also think of recombination and
CRISPR cast 9 tying into a genomic
framework and the whole idea is how many
more generations can you turn per year
and so ideally this would result in
faster development of more resilient
crops and in this case cotton so of
course we have our training population
and we do genotyping and phenotyping on
that training population and to train
our GF model but phenotyping is still
very important because when you think
about the prediction accuracy highly
heritable phenotypes and high quality
phenotypes is what's driving a lot of
that GS model and so there's obviously a
lot of improvements that can be made to
these GS models where you know you're
training on a genotypic in phenotypic
data set and then you're trying to
predict the phenotype of a related
population that has been only genotype
and phenotype
in is what I decided to focus on at that
time back in 2009 but coming into it we
all knew that the classic genotyping as
I talked about earlier plant breeders
know how to do very well plant readers
are very industrious in a sense
Bilbo's hire an army and that's how they
get the job done but when you're working
in an environment such as Arizona which
has sometimes temperatures over 100
degrees Fahrenheit you need to work a
lot more intelligently or you won't last
very long in the field so there's a time
intensive component to it often if
you're doing plant physiological traits
the sample sizes are fairly small and
you can only do perhaps like a few time
points as well and often from a plant
breeding I
there's obviously trade bias in a sense
you tended only phenotype what you can
visually score or perhaps you're just
driving a combine at the end of the
season and when it comes to hiring a
large field crew that is also very
expensive
so this is my colleague here Mike salvo
Qi and he introduced me to the like
horse 6400 I was all enamored with it at
first until I realized how much of a
pain it was having to work in that
intense heat and to realize you would
sit and maybe for a half an hour in
front of a couple plants and you
wouldn't really get that much phenotypic
data some of the phenotypic data that we
were able to get would be like
transpiration rate and cama to be
temperature and we also had a FLIR
camera that we could shoot in in front
of these and here this picture than a
pima cotton if you do not know what pima
cotton is it has nice long fiber and
that's what that high thread count
sheets that that you have but at that
time we were really thinking about how
do we do this a lot faster
it isn't that we're lazy we just want to
have very large population and we want
to be able to really cover all the
different developmental time points of a
plant as they are growing over the
growing season and we want to be as
objective of we can possibly be and we
want to do this at low cost so there was
an agricultural engineer that I began
talking to in
9 Pater njarraud 8 Sanchez and in a
sense we found this tractor in the
junkyard and it needed a new engine and
a new tires and everything so here I'm
showing I think at this time version
tree I'm sorry version 2 version 1
tractor high clearance tractor we just
pulled out of a junkyard put in a new
motor put some new tires on put this
tool bar arm and we're set to go so the
idea of sensor fusion is in a sense
combining all these different data
streams to be able to use them and get
as much information out of in terms of
trying to understand what is the crop
doing over these various time points of
a growing season and if you're imposing
in this case heat and drought stress and
some of the phenotypes that we were
focusing on first was a vegetation index
and that's focused up in here these are
called crop circles we had our T's on
the tractor as well and they are
pointing down over the the crop right
here and that's to do phenotyping of
canopy temperature and here we have the
ultrasonic transducers that's pointed
right here and that's what we were able
to do canopy height and we had our TK
GPS on the tractor so in essence we're
able to re resolve and D convolute all
these Expedia typic data points down to
individual plants in a plot and we're
able to do that entirely and repeatedly
over the growing season so the first leg
thing that you do kind of as a plant
breeder is think about okay we're able
to collect all this perhaps gigabytes
and terabytes of phenotypic data but is
it of value is it heritable is a
repeatable so one of the first things
that you know I basically want to do is
here we were testing this on 25 Pima
cultivars and here we have on the y-axis
canopy temperature and on the x-axis
leaf relative water content and what
this is basically showing is this canopy
temperature is chapping with changes in
the soil
water relationship whereas the drive
plots have a higher canopy temperature
because the transpiration rate is
reduced of those plants because they're
trying to conserve water so the
transformation rate is shut down and in
turn the canopy temperature is
increasing and here in the blue or on
these would be and you can kind of view
them as control plots so these are the
well water wet plots and the
transpiration rate is high because these
plants aren't shutting down and they're
able to continue to cool the the crop
canopy and we had heard from Todd about
this vegetation index called NDVI which
ties in red and near-infrared and what
this is really typically doing its
innocence quantifying biomass but it's
also tying in leaf area index
chlorophyll content and coverage of the
actual plant canopy itself but what we
saw here over time of these 25 Pima
cultivars is the plots that are dry they
begin to decrease their NDVI value over
time and what this response was actually
capturing is the degree to which the
plants will because here you see a pima
cotton columns of artists under intense
drought and you can see the the leaves
will so this is a vegetation index that
is in a sense capturing greenness so as
the leaves droop there's more soil
exposed up through the canopy and also
as the leaves wilt they're changing
their conformation as well and that's
changing the pattern of leaf reflection
as well and that's why those values are
decreasing so this was like kind of a
fun way to see if you can plot this over
time within the actual day is capturing
biomass but in our eyes now we're able
to use it to see the degree to which the
plants actually wilt so we were able to
also see that this system was repeatable
over the growing season
assuming that the canopy was closed and
that's the drip irrigation was not
clogged because there are challenges
when you're growing on drip irrigation
and it is being cleared out right you
need to pump some sulfuric acid through
there and clean it up just right and
things again flowing very well but as we
saw is when we were doing its high
kickers phenotyping with the tractor we
could easily see parts of the field from
the response of the plants where the
drip tape was actually clogged because
those were the plants that were heating
up very fast and then you would just
pump into this also I'll tear gas and
clear it out and it cleans it up just
fine and so here we have the same high
clearance tractor system and here I'm
calling field Bates hydro flood plan
phenotyping system and it's QTL mapping
of different traits over time so if you
haven't thought about GTL in this sense
you can just think of a key TL as a
quantitative trait locus what innocence
is just a chromosomal region controlling
phenotypic variance in that part of the
genome so in a sense we have this
recombinant inbred line population up
close to 100 recombinant inbred lines
and these recombinant inbred lines are a
mosaic of the two parents in a sense you
shuffle up the genome and then you're
using the patterns of recombination to
track these regions of the genome with
the phenotypic variation and if those
particular regions of the genome are
showing up that's what we're referring
to as a QTL so here we also have our
field base height spread phenotyping
system we did these various agronomic
traits such as lint yield both size and
private quality and thanks to Tim cetera
at the time we were also able to
phenotype a size like acid concentration
as a physiological leaf trait and as I
was saying this was all grown and drip
irrigation and we had a little Neutron
probe in the field which if you've ever
put these in you can feel our pain
because we
after duties readings every week before
and after turning on the drip irrigation
and the great thing about having a drip
irrigation you can have a set time so in
the sense the plants are almost trained
very well when you're turning on and off
the drip irrigation and this is a shot
of the actual field right here in
Maricopa Arizona so here what this is is
basically recapitulating a canopy
temperature heat map of the field and
each of these little circles or pixels
right here are an actual phenotypic data
point that was taken by the high
clearance tractor and so if you recall
we have these four IR TS on the tractor
so we're able to do phenotyping of four
rows at a time and the cooler the canopy
is the bluer it is and you see these
little areas are here those are our
alleys in the field here and so this is
a control treatment right here so here
would would be the the dry drought
treatment right here and here you can
see the the canopy temperature is
heating up but you can see this part of
the field right here is actually cooler
and when we ran in e/m 38 and checked
out the conductivity of the soil what we
had found out this part of the field had
a higher clay content and so if you do
any drought testing and if you do the
thing you should always understand is
there's more variation for the soil than
their actual traits that you're
phenotyping in your plant populations so
you have to control for this type of
field variation in your models or you'll
just end up being a breeder breeding for
soil type and you wouldn't be the first
one that has so the the great thing here
is that canopy temperature turned out to
be highly heritable in this recombinant
inbred line population and in this case
shows transgressive segregation and what
that transition actually means is you
have progenies that exceeds the
phenotypic values of
the actual parents and these are the two
parents here and I'm 24 of 16 and tm-1
and these are the control plots here wet
and these are the drive plots here in
red and you can see the control plots
here wet had a heritability broad sense
of 0.8 3 and this is heritability of 0.9
these carrot of building values
generally range between 0 and 1 and they
happen to be quite high here because one
thing to keep in mind we were doing
genotyping at three time points within a
single day so it's really taking in all
of that variance within the actual day
and that's helping to increase the
heritability of the phenotype itself and
since we have the trap there we can do
phenotyping over the entire growing
season here so if you ever and having
taught about cotton growing so here we
go from seed to perhaps eight nodes
four to five weeks out the first bloom
and then you have to add a defoliant to
force all of the leaves to fall off
because cotton is a poor in a perennial
tree just treat it as an annual crop
okay and and the great thing is you know
here's when the trials our planet we
have equal irrigation applied to both
the wet and dry treatment and these are
the phenotypes that we had targeted for
different time points so canopy
temperature canopy NDVI which does
remind use of vegetation index and then
canopy height and then we began opposing
the differential irrigation at flowering
because we didn't want confounding
because that's why we didn't do it early
on prior to flowering because also as a
few of you probably know often when
people are breeding for drought
tolerance it's actually drought escape
and the QTL can to be just genes for
flowering time and that's one thing that
we wanted to avoid and then at the end
of season we're driving like a cotton
picker through the field and harvesting
and so here what we have is canopy
temperature over the whole growing
season and then we were able to break up
these basically days
of the year into the different
developmental growth phases of cotton so
here we have flowering at peak bloom
full development and fiber development
in elongation this is at 7:00 in the
morning 10 a.m. 1 p.m. and 3 p.m. and
the red here is a dry treatment and the
blue is the wet treatment here and what
you kind of see on this axis here this
is the canopy temperature here and as
you increase the temperature in terms of
Lake during the day the phenotypic
variance is also increasing as as well
as the plants are becoming more hotter
and and so when you think about this we
were able to now break up the plan into
the different development in all phases
and what we found is the canopy
temperature feeding pipes themselves are
more highly correlated with in a plant
growth stage so what's that's telling
you is they're somewhat maybe a
coordination of genes some itself within
an actual plant growth stage so then
this gave us the idea okay since we're
seeing these patterns what that may
suggest that the there is maybe certain
QTL in terms of their expression
patterns turning on and off in the
genome over the growth phase of the
cotton recombinant inbred line
population and some of that is perturbed
by heat and heat and drought stress and
in fact that is actually what we found
so here we have what we're revealing
here is this distinct temporal patters
of the QTL effects that's controlling
canopy temperature variation is
recombinant inbred line population so
this is the qtls that we detected under
the control wet treatment here these are
the Kentucky L that we controlled under
the dry treatment here and these are the
effects of the QTL that decrease canopy
temperature here they're in blue and in
the red our GTL accepts that in our
increasing canopy temperature but what
you can see here is depending on the age
of the actual plant that's when QT
are actually being triggered and turned
on and intensity if if you will the size
of the effect of the key TL is also
partly being driven by the drought
treatment and the great thing about a
genome is you can find any possible
candidate gene that you want so here in
in this region of the cotton genome
where we had a key TL map we found a
gene for an ABA response factor and one
of the the things that I found was
pretty exciting at the time is that the
key TL for variability in cotton leaf
ABA content also mapped to that same
region of the genome and why that seems
to jive is in a sense when you have ABA
it's contributing to what the model size
and how its going to open and close
right so it's quite possible that this
QTL is in fact contributing to variation
in transpiration rate in this part of
the genome and that would obviously then
drive changes in canopy temperature and
dr. Du Polly contributed to this paper
and I believe he is here you can ask
them all about it and and so then we
also want to think about in terms of
breeding and when here on the x-axis
here we have lint yields and temperature
on the y-axis what we have found is you
know that increase in leaf transpiration
rate under drought stress actually
contributes to higher lint yield in a
heavily irrigated hot arid environment
so these plants over here are the ones
that take a risk under drought in a
sense they're not shutting down and
they're continuing to have a high
transpiration rate and by having that
they can continue to six-carbon and in a
sense have higher yield
these plants over here are the ones that
decide to shut down and they're going to
fix less carbon now right and so they
will yield less so in a heavily
irrigated environment such as Elle West
in Arizona you would perhaps
genotypes such as this one right here
but if you're in a dry land in
environment that's only rain said
perhaps you would want a genotype that's
more conservative over in this region
here and that will perhaps be calibrated
to use water only perhaps a like fill of
the grain or a flowering and what we
also found is at all these various time
points that we did phenotyping across
the field season the most informative
was at flowering because the reason why
is after you have all this heat what's
going to suffer in this case it's going
to be the flowers themselves so if
there's high heat the pollen isn't going
to be viable and if it isn't going to be
viable there isn't going to be seed set
and there isn't going to be any fiber
and so here it's a fun part with lidar
work so you're putting this on our
tractor and now we're trying to recreate
the the 3d shape of the foliated cotton
plants in the field so this is our
entire field right here and this is one
say like 28 foot plot of defoliated
cotton plants and what you could see
here is all these cloud points and todd
was touching down clown points and his
talk and in a sense these are
recapitulating the actual cotton balls
on on the plants and we can actually
take out like a single plant and do a
euclidean clustering approach and
innocence try to get closer to yield and
we're here we're just counting the
cotton bowls on the plant so I think
there's a lot of future in that so now
let's turn to deep learning which we all
love and artificial intelligence
so since coming to Cornell's they're
working with some plant pathologists
which I found are exciting people to
work with and oh hey hey Chris how you
doing so one of the questions we had
here we have a phenotype that's caused
by this pathogen and it's
the is northern corn leaf blight say you
hire maybe four or five undergrads you
show them one leaf and you force them
out to go to the field and they have to
now do phenotyping for NCLB well you
just show them this one which has NCLB
but they see all these other examples
here Wow wouldn't it be so much easier
just to train a robot well at least
that's what I thought but obviously it's
important to invest in our youth of
tomorrow so so this idea is training
these convolutional neural networks so
this is what you refer to as in the old
days deep learning and now AI so the
idea is to combine this with drones to
detect these NLB lesions on made sleeves
in the field and to turn drones to just
you know for just being something fun
you see flying around or trying to tear
out of my kids hands when we're going to
target is that you're actually turning
them into a co-worker and a colleague
now so the the idea is you have your
drones flying over top of plots of maize
and you have your RGB 3dr IRIScan in
here and then here is a disease lesion
but obviously you don't want to take as
I said early perhaps like eighty
thousand images and try to pick these
out by eye you wanted to train the CN NS
into detecting clb in maze the challenge
is we haven't evolved to the point where
the AIS can train themselves but I'm
sure that's coming in in the future
so here you can just kind of view it at
the CN n here is converting pixels into
words and the gossip thing doesn't need
to be linear so you can use curves and
shapes and everything like that
but this is where presence/absence in a
human being
terrain plant pathologists have to
classify this is the disease lesion or
it is a knot and I and I've been told by
the colleagues on his project after they
would do maybe several hundred bees per
day when David close their
eyes they would see disease lesions on
the back of their eyelids when they
would go to bed at night so I do feel
kind of horrible for it for that but
it's all in the name of science so here
we we have this was taking from if you
will a person as they walk through the
field with a handheld camera so you can
kind of view this from the point of view
of like a ground vehicle and we also
have all the ones from the drones that
we're training on right now and this
this case we trained on close to to 2000
photos that have been classified so here
we have our AI and these are all our
diseased lesions here and our AI this is
kind of viewed as a heat map and if it's
white that means it has a probability
you know of in a sense that is a disease
lesion if it's black there is none where
where it's black and so that's when it
when they are present and if they aren't
present then you should have an AI
trained very well so that you shouldn't
detect any lesions when there are none
present and in this case here we do not
find anything at all and after training
on these 2000s for this set that we have
we found maybe we're only wrong maybe 2
to 3 percent of the time so I think they
were doing pretty good perhaps when we
trained on 10,000 more we can maybe in
increase that even more so this is like
a very fun active area of research and
in my lab and on our bread project it's
kind of the same concept and now
changing to our handheld phones and this
is a colleague of mine where he in a
sense has developed AI to detect the
disease that's infecting like cassava
plant and in this case a a farmer or a
breeder can take a picture of a diseased
cassava plant and then the AI runs on
the phone or actually it can be sent to
to to to cloud where it's processed
there as well and then with a certain
probability it'll tell you what cassava
disease it actually has and in in in the
future for our terror project that we
have we've kind of taken the pro
four are trying to develop low-cost
autonomous field robots that can go
through the fields and here and with our
colleagues at University of UIUC and the
idea here is so you can do canopy
reflectance canopy temperature and
canopy geometry and its onboard
processing as this can transect like the
plots in the field and it's recording
other climatic factors such as like soil
temperature air temperature as well so
our first leg version one is it'll cost
about 200k but we're very hopeful that
we can get the price down to like 20k
and then we can kind of think of a world
where we have these in everyone's hand
and then so we're testing this on
biomass sorghum and in my group we're
creating a hapmap for a few hundred
lines and an idea is where you can then
develop like a time series for like G by
E as all these variants in the hapmap
across the genome and see like genes
that are being turned on and off as I
was showing what I caught but really
beginning to factor in that Jeep ie come
component to try to figure out why it is
being turned on and off and what I think
about in the future where where I kind
of see my work proceeding is breeders
have a tremendous eye and I think at
some point we can clone it with with AI
and when you have these autonomous
breeding now I know I'm not going to
call them autonomous breeders they're
going to assist the breeders because of
course we don't want to replace the
breeders but what we want to do is
basically clone the breeders I and
perhaps maybe have maybe 10 to 20 of
these very low-cost robots
per breeder and perhaps there's maybe
some some simplistic traits and early
generation breeding such as height plant
pathology traits
that if you have maybe tens of thousands
of like head rows or something like that
that these robots could actually go
through and help pinpoint and then
tracked by GPS certain plants in the
field and then if the breeder isn't
happy with the plans that are chosen and
he or should she can just re retrain the
AI so I think we're kind of at a point
now when we need to be having that
conversation with all the computer
scientists all of the robotic engineers
on campus to really push our signs to a
place that we've haven't really
conceived quite yet because these things
are now becoming possible and I think
Cornell is at a place where we can drive
this to become a reality
and I'll let's thank all of my
colleagues and with that I will take
maybe one questions that I want to keep
you from your break and then we can
resume back at 11:00 all right thank you
[Applause]
yeah
when I think of my field in Aurora New
York I want to build a robot that can go
out and pick every stone out of my
people that's the first one I would do
but I think the area in the Bairro
typing is like going to be I think the
future so if you can think of having
maybe low-cost ways since at the plots
like soil temperature how much soil
water moisture is in each plot and then
in a certain area you can record the
ambient air temperature and like other
factors over the whole growing season
then you can think about you know doing
factorial regression and trying to
figure out what is the contribution of
these changes in the e that's
contributing to my GMI G by E over the
whole growing season so I think there
there are some things that are coming
out now but they're not cheap enough to
you to the point where you're able just
to put one probe per like one plot so
perhaps you can try to like characterize
the actual variation in your field and
then use like an approach to try to like
like close that gap if you will to kind
of fill in those void areas where you
have no probe so that's what I think we
really need to kind of go towards the G
by E question yeah all right thank you
everyone see you at 11:00
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu